TUCKER IS NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
RUSSIA IS BACK IN THE NEWS ALL
OF HIS SUDDEN.
WE WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR FRIENDS
AT CNN, FOR TAKING THE BREAK
COMMODE THERE WAS A POINT WE
WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT A RUSSIA.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE PREMISE OF
THE NOW DISCREDITED TO YOUR LONG
INVESTIGATION WAS THAT IT WAS
ENTIRELY IMPLAUSIBLE, INDEED IT
WAS LIKELY THAT DONALD TRUMP, A
FORMER CASINO OWNER WHO SPENT 14
SEASONS STARRING ON AN NBC
REALITY SHOW, WAS IN FACT
DESPITE ALL OUTWARD APPEARANCES
TO THE CONTRARY, A SECRET
RUSSIAN AGENT WORKING AGAINST
AMERICAN INTERESTS TO SERVE
VLADIMIR PUTIN IN MOSCOW.
MANY NONGENUS IS BELIEVED IT WAS
TRUE.
THEY REPEATED THE ALLEGATION
EVERY SINGLE DAY FOR EVERY
SINGLE YEAR BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THEY DO BEST.
BUT THE MUCH MORE INTERESTING
AND IMPORTANT QUESTION HAS
ALWAYS BEEN THIS: WHAT DID
SENIOR LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
THINK OF THE STORY?
DID THEY REALLY BELIEVE IT WAS
POSSIBLE THAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
WORKING FOR RUSSIA?
AND IF SO, WHAT EVIDENCE THEY
HAVE RUSSIAN MARK IF THEY HAVE
NO EVIDENCE, WHY DID THEY OPEN
THE INVESTIGATION AND WHAT ARE
THEY CONTINUING?
FOR YEARS, EVERY AMERICAN
REGARDLESS OF PARTY HAS BEEN
INTERESTED IN KNOWING THE ANSWER
THOSE QUESTIONS AND FOR MORE
THAN A YEAR, THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S OFFICE HAS WORKED TO
FIND THE ANSWER.
THE REPORT FINALLY CAME PUBLIC,
AND EVEN BEFORE IT DID, SOME OF
THE MOUTH BREEDERS ON TELEVISION
WERE HAPPY TO GUESS ITS
CONCLUSION.
THEY PROCLAIM THE FBI COMPLETE
INNOCENT OF ALL WRONGDOING
BECAUSE IN 2019, BEING A
PROGRESSIVE MEANS TAKING THE
SIDES OF BUREAUCRATS WITH GUNS
THE MATTER WHAT THE EVIDENCE IS.
WATCH.
>> THE HEADLINE WILL BE WHETHER
YOU ARE A TRUMP SUPPORTER OR
TRUMP SKEPTIC THAT THE FBI IS
EXONERATED TODAY FROM THE OFT
REPEATED SMEAR THAT THERE WAS
SOME SORT OF CAMPAIGN -- IT'S
GOOD NEWS NO MATTER WHERE YOU
STAND ON THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
IN 2019.
>> Martha: KEEP IN
SPEED TO KEEP IN MIND WHEN SHE
UTTERED THOSE WORDS, SHE HAD NOT
EVEN
READ THE IG REPORT.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
HAVE FORMER FLAXEN SPOKESPERSON
ON JOURNALISM.
THE ACTUAL REPORT WAS SOMETHING
OF A DISASTER FOR THE FBI.
OBVIOUS TO ANYBODY WHO READ IT,
EVEN PEOPLE WHO WORK AT MSNBC.
>> WHAT IT BASICALLY SAID THAT
THE FBI SCREWED UP AT BASICALLY
EVERY LEVEL, FAILING TO PAY
ENOUGH ATTENTION TO POTENTIAL
PROBLEMS WITH STEELE.
THE REPORT SAYS THE FISA
APPLICATION WAS INACCURATE,
INCOMPLETE, OR UNSUPPORTED.
IT SAYS, FOR EXAMPLE, THE FBI
FAILED TO LOOK AT SOME OF THE
PROBLEM IN STEELE'S PAST WORK.
THAT WAS NEVER ADDRESSED.
>> Tucker: THERE IS THE
UNDERSTATEMENT OF THE WEEK.
IN FACT, STEELE'S SO-CALLED
DOSSIER WAS ABSURD.
NO JUDGMENT NEWS OUTLET WOULD
RUN IT.
SO CLEARLY FALSE THAT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" KEPT ITS
DISTANCE.
IT'S UP TO BUZZFEED TO RUN IT, A
CATS BLOG.
THE ONE THAT NO ONE WOULD PRINT
BECAUSE IT WAS SO FALSE
COMMITTEE USE IT AS A PRETEXT TO
SPY ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
A A
KEEP IN MIND, WHEN YOU ARE
LYING, THE MORE SPECIFIC THE LIE
IS, THE MORE LIKELY IT IS TO BE
BELIEVED.
THE LIGHT IN THE DOSSIER WAS HE
WAS OFFERED 19%, NOT 18, 20, 19%
INTEREST IN THE ENERGY COUNTRY
IF HE CAN PERSUADE DONALD TRUMP
TO LIFT SANCTIONS AGAINST
MOSCOW.
THE CLAIM WAS WRONG.
IT WAS A LIE.
PAGE WAS A NAVAL OFFICER AND I
HAD DONE NOTHING WRONG.
THE FBI TARGETED HIM ANYWAY.
PROMINENT FIGURES ON THE LEFT
ACCUSED HIM OF BETRAYING HIS
COUNTRY.
CARTER PAGE'S LIFE WAS DESTROYED
WORST OF ALL AND THIS IS WHAT WE
LEARNED TODAY, THE FBI KNEW
EXACTLY WHAT WAS HAPPENING AND
THEY KEPT DOING IT.
THE FISA WARRANT AGAINST PAIGE,
THE ONE THAT ALLOWED THEM TO SPY
ON HIM, HAD TO BE REDONE
MULTIPLE TIMES.
ACCORDING TO THE IG REPORT, THE
FBI REPEATEDLY LIED AND EXCLUDED
COMETARY INFORMATION TO KEEP
THAT SPEED 26 WARRANT ALIVE
SHOWING THAT THE DOCUMENT WAS
UNRELIABLE, THEY CONTINUE TO
TREAT PAGE AS CRIMINAL AND
STEELE AS A TRUSTED SOURCE FOR
THE USUAL, HALF-WITS, AND
PARTISANS CONTINUE TO ACCUSE
PAGE OF SOMETHING HE NEVER
COMMITTED.
>> CONSPIRING WITH RUSSIA IN
WAYS THAT WERE NEFARIOUS.
>> OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE TO HAVE
PROBABLE CAUSE.
IT WOULD BE A DIRECTION OF DUTY
TO NOT HAVE SOUGHT A
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT.
>> MAKES A COMPELLING CASE THAT
THERE IS PROBABLE CAUSE TO
BELIEVE THAT CARTER PAGE IS
ACTING IN A FOREIGN POWER.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE IF THAT WAS
YOU, SOMEBODY ON TELEVISION
EVERY DAY IN FACT ACCUSING YOU
OF TREASON AND CONGRESSMEN AND
TV REPORTS ALL NODDED IN
AGREEMENT -- THAT SOUNDS RIGHT.
THE FBI KNEW YOU DIDN'T DO IT,
BUT INSTEAD LIFTS THE BURDEN OF
SUSPICION OFF YOUR SHOULDERS,
INSTEAD LIE IN ORDER TO HIDE
YOUR INNOCENCE?
THAT WAS CARTER PAGE A PROCESS
LIE FOR YEARS BUT HARD TO
BELIEVE IT COULD HAPPEN IN THIS
COUNTRY, BUT IT DID HAPPEN.
LET'S HOPE CARTER PAGE SPENDS
THE REST OF HIS LIFE SUING EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE PEOPLE IN
BANKRUPTCY, AND IT SHOULD
INCLUDE MALICIOUS LIARS LIKE CIA
HEAD AND CNN CONTRIBUTE OR JOHN
BRENNAN, WATCH HIM SAY SOMETHING
WITH A STRAIGHT FACE NOW WE KNOW
IS ACTUALLY FALSE.
>> DO YOU KNOW WHO COMMISSION
THE STEELE DOSSIER?
>> I DON'T.
>> DID THE CIA RELY ON IT?
>> NO.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE IT WASN'T PART OF THE
CORPUS OF INTELLIGENCE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAD.
IT WAS NOT IN ANY WAY USED AS A
BASIS FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY ASSESSMENT THAT WAS
DONE.
>> Tucker: YES, IT WASN'T IN
ANY WAY.
YES, THE BASIS OF THAT
ASSESSMENT.
CARTER PAGE WAS NOT THE ONLY AND
IS CAUGHT UP IN THE WITCH HUNT,
AND WITCH HUNT IS NOT AN
OVERSTATEMENT.
ACCORDING TO THE REPORT, THE FBI
EMPLOYED UNDERCOVER AGENTS TO
COLLECT INTELLIGENCE ON THE
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE BUREAU ITSELF USED A
DEFENSIVE BRIEFING TO MONITOR
WHAT THE CAMPAIGN WAS DOING.
DEFENSIVE BRIEFINGS ARE DESIGNED
FOR THE GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
THE BUREAU SHARES INTELLIGENCE
WITH LEADING POTENTIAL
CANDIDATES OR PRESIDENT-ELECT SO
THEY'LL HAVE A GROUNDING WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE WORLD WHEN THEY
TAKE CONTROL.
IN THIS CASE, HOWEVER, THE FBI
USE THAT BRIEFING THE SPY ON
TRUMP STAFF AND BUILD CRIMINAL
CASES AGAINST THEM.
CAN YOU IMAGINE A QUESTION LIKE
THE IG REPORT CLAIMS AND IF THIS
IS CLEARLY MOTIVATED.
THAT'S A SUBJECTIVE JUDGMENT.
HARD TO KNOW, BUT IT'S ALSO HARD
TO SWALLOW THAT CLAIM.
ONLY A PARTISAN CAN BELIEVE
SOMETHING SO ABSURD AS THIS
BETWEEN
STTWEEN
STEEEEN
STEELEN
STEELE DOSSIER.
THE FACTS REMAIN TO THE FBI USE
FLIMSY EXCUSES TO SPY ON THE
AMERICAN CITIZEN AND RIVAL A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THEY ENGAGE IN ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR
TO MAKE SURE THE SPINE
CONTINUED ILLEGITIMATELY.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE MOTIVE
FOR ALL OF THAT WAS.
THE FACTS ALONE OUGHT TO SCARE
YOU.
FORMER DIRECTOR JIM COMEY
THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A MINUTE.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW, MUELLER
OUGHT TO BE GROVELING FOR
FORGIVENESS -- HE OUGHT TO
BE RELOCATING TO PARAGUAY IN SHA
BE RELOCATING TO PARAGUAY IN SHE
BE RELOCATING TO PARAGUAY IN SH.
IN FACT, HE'S MORE
SELF-RIGHTEOUS THAN EVER.
JIM COMEY IS A GOOD PERSON --
UNFORTUNATELY, YOU ARE NOT.
APPROVED BY A FEDERAL JUDGE,
COMEY TELLS US.
AMIDST THE FACT THAT THE FBI
LIED TO THE JUDGE.
THE FBI DID NOT INSERT SPIES IN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, NO, THEY
JUST USE SPIES TO MONITOR THE
TRUMP STAFF.
JIM COMEY DOES NOT THINK YOU
HAVE GOOGLE OR DOESN'T CARE YOU
HAVE GOOGLE.
DOESN'T CARE WHAT YOU KNOW, THEY
COULD ISSUE A HUNDRED IG
REPORTS, ALL OF THEM EXPOSING